a local principal in north las vegas
getting national recognition for taking
work in his own hands literally his
school is dealing with staff shortages
madison kimbrough went to gwendolyn
wooley elementary school to talk to
principal ue about the work that he is
doing
have you ever heard of a principal
cleaning school toilets or stripping
floors well here at gwendolyn wooly
elementary school in north las vegas
that's what principal oohy is doing in
the midst of being short staffed we've
had staffing shortage even before
coveted principal joseph ue taking one
for the team so to speak at gwendolyn
wooley elementary school in north las
vegas knowing how much needs to get done
and not having the staff to do it he
isn't afraid of getting his hands dirty
you're at woolly i tried to instill the
all hands on deck
mentality
next man up kind of thing and so when we
were
short staffed with with custodial so i
asked my
my custodial and said what do you want
me to do what can i do and so he said
well i need help stripping the floor and
waxing i said let me show me show me one
and i'll do the rest ue gaining national
attention from cbs news who came to las
vegas to talk to him about stepping up
in this time of need he says helping out
like this may seem unconventional as a
principal but to him it's truly what his
role at wooly is all about if i expect
my custodian to do that then i should be
able to to clean toilets and and help in
the cafeteria and the same token in the
classroom i've uh i've hit the classroom
teaching uh because we were sort of sub
one of the things i wanted to uh promote
is just to improve the climate and
culture and so in doing that i think
they're able to teach our students
at a level where i wanted to be and
principal oui says that while they are
short staff his team works at an
incredible pace to get everything done
his goal is to create an environment
that kids want to be in and staff wants
to work at reporting in north las vegas
madison kimbrough live local now